mes amis dans 100 jours les français
éliront leur président de la république
et sous la vème république
l'élection présidentielle c'est le point
d'orgue de notre engagement
bien sûr gagner les élections
municipales
c'est enthousiasmant cher florence
berthoud maire du vème arrondissement
qui nous accueille et que nous pouvons
applaudir bien sûr conquérir un
département c'est un vrai défi cher
edouard courtial
bien sûr ma chère valérie vous pourrez
l'applaudir autres filles bien sûr ma
chère valérie remporter une région c'est
un fait d'armes politique mais gagner
l'élection présidentielle
c'est notre raison d'être c'est ce qui
guide notre engagement c'est une
expérience inouïe dans nos vies de
militants souvenez-vous de
l'enthousiaste qui a accompagné
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy en 2007
souvenez-vous de la ferveur de
l'élection de jacques chirac en 95
en remontant plus loin mon cher jean
pierre souvenons nous la dynamique qui
avait été créée par giscard devant la
jeunesse en 74 et bien mes chers amis
mon cher françois
la victoire à l'élection présidentielle
ça devra d'abord être celle de nos
valeurs ça devrait être celle de nos
idées ça devrait être le triomphe des
convictions pour lesquels chaque jour
nous nous battons et si le parlement de
notre parti est aujourd'hui rassembler
derrière toi c'est parce que nous te
faisons confiance pour défendre ses
convictions et pour les incarner
il ne peut y avoir de place dans les
prochaines semaines pour la bouderie
pour la rancune pour les petits calculs
personnels
nous avons pour un certain d'entre nous
nos fidélité et je peux en témoigner mon
cher françois tu ne nous a jamais
demandé d'y renoncer
mais mes amis les choses sont claires
aujourd'hui nous sommes rassemblés
derrière françois fillon pour le faire
gagner
et pour faire gagner nos idées
à mon sens cette élection présidentielle
est sans doute celle de la dernière
chance de la dernière chance pour la
france d'accéder à ce nouveau monde qui
nous tend les bras et auquel nous nous
évertuons à tourner le dos depuis trop
longtemps
sans cette victoire la france se
condamne à rester éternellement sur le
seuil de ce nouveau monde à mourir des
classes est asphyxié dans l'antichambre
du 21e siècle à subir
telle une coquille de noix ballotté par
les tempêtes les crises politiques
géopolitiques économiques un être cher
que de son passé
abandonnant son destin et celui des
français dans les mains du hasard ou de
l'incertitude dans le monde du 21e
siècle
mes amis il n'y a pas de place qui est
garanti
rien est offert personne ne nous attend
on peut émerger comme on peut
disparaître tout est à conquérir un
force de réactivité
à force d'agilité à force d'imagination
à force de créativité et bien il est
grand temps d'ouvrir sur ce nouveau
monde les yeux
enfin un monde fascinant un monde où le
projet technique scientifique et
désormais exponentielle
songez mes chers amis que dans les dix
prochaines années
moins de deux quinquennats mon cher
françois la connaissance mondiale va
doubler oui l'humanité va produire plus
de connaissances dans les dix prochaines
années qu'elle n'en a produit au cours
de ces sept mille premières années de
son histoire qu'elles sont dérisoires
les querelles sur les polémiques sur le
déremboursement des rhumes
quand on sait que les nanotechnologies
que les bio technologies vont
révolutionner la santé quand on sait que
désormais des globules rouges vont être
produits à partir de cellules souches
quand on sait
qu'on peut maintenant créer des tissus
humains à partir d'imprimantes 3d le
monde de demain le monde qui nous attend
sur lequel les français nous attendent
c'est un monde à la vitesse accélérée ou
le déluge d'informations va doubler la
capacité de nos data tous les deux ans
ou l'hypermobilité va être la règle
un monde qui va remettre en cause nos
quotidiens un monde où la robotique les
capteurs l'impression 3d vont
bouleverser nos usines nos emplois nos
modes de production
mes chers amis si je vous dis ça c'est
parce que je considère que l'élection
présidentielle s'est pas uniquement la
question de savoir si on va réserver 40
ou 50 poseront conception à lui dit
c'est pas uniquement la question de
savoir si macro et de droite ou de
gauche
non la question c'est de savoir si la
france elle est capable d'entrer dans ce
nouveau monde
eh bien oui mes chers amis elle sera
capable de rentrer dans ce nouveau monde
avec un programme audacieux avec un
programme réformateur avec le programme
de françois fillon
courant des la france après cinq années
de socialisme
après cinq années de françois hollande
la france elle se réjouit triomphalement
d'être le premier pays au monde à avoir
inventé le droit à la déconnexion la
déconnexion g vous dire c'est ce qui
illustre finalement assez bien le mandat
de françois hollande est bien le
programme de françois fillon au
programme mon cher françois
il doit permettre en disant tu le dit
régulièrement de faire de la france la
première puissance économie dire en
disant d'europe c'est possible mes amis
c'est possible en faisant ce qu'ont fait
nos voisins en commençant cher gilles
carez par réduire massivement la dépense
publique oui nous devons réduire la
dépense publique
pas pour faire plaisir à bruxelles pas
par dogme tout simplement pour enlever
le sac de plomb qui pèse sur tous les
créateurs de ce pays on ne peut pas
continuer à être les champions des
dépenses publiques en y consacrant 57 %
de notre création de richesse parce que
si on est les champions de la dépense
publique
on est forcément les champions des
impôts et des taxes pour les financer
avec 45 % du produit intérieur brut
si vous commencez le match dans la
compétition qui nous oppose à
l'allemagne alors qu'on vous prélève 45
% de votre richesse et bien vous n'avez
aucune chance de le gagner face à votre
concurrent allemand qui lui à qui on va
prélever 30 6% 9 points d'écart et bien
forcément comme on disait dans les
années 80 en football c'est l'allemagne
qui gagne à la fin
et bien moi je veux qu'on montre
maintenant que c'est plus l'allemagne
qui gagne
afin que nous allons réformer notre
économie que nous allons pays c'est la
dépense publique et que nous allons
revenir dans le jeu j'entends dire ici
ou là ça n'est pas possible de réduire
la dépense publique de 100 milliards
d'euros
mais enfin faisons ensemble un rapide
calcul mes amis le som la somme de la
dépense publique en france c'est 1200
milliards d'euros 100 milliards
d'économies en cinq ans
ces 20 milliards d'économies par an 20
milliards sur 1200 1,6 pour cent
quelle est l'entreprise quel est le
ménage ici dans la salle qui n'est pas
capable de réaliser 1,6 % d'économies
par an ouvrons les yeux mes amis
j'entends dire ça va être difficile de
supprimer 500 mille emplois de
fonctionnaires j'aurais juste rappeler
un chiffre en 30 ans le nombre de
fonctionnaires dans notre pays a
augmenté de 36%
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que la
france est mieux administrer aujourd'hui
elle a augmenté de 36% ce nombre alors
que la population augmente et en
parallèle de 18%
la france a aujourd'hui 80
fonctionnaires pour 1000 habitants
l'allemagne lille la grande bretagne 45
et si on supprime ce que prévoit le
programme de françois fillon
cinq cent mille postes de fonctionnaires
il y en aura en 2022 plus qu'il y en
avait quand lionel jospin était premier
ministre
alors ouvrons les yeux mes amis assez de
désinformation de grave oui françois tu
as raison de parler de plein emploi
c'est possible d'autres l'ont fait
autour de nous et quand j'entends là
encore certains dire sur la lutte contre
le chômage on a tout essayé les amis on
a tout essayé sur ce qui marche
on a tout essayé sauf qu'a réussi
ailleurs
en allemagne en grande-bretagne aux
etats-unis nous réussirons comme en
baissant les charges des entreprises
pour abaisser le coût du travail sur
tous les niveaux de salaire pas
uniquement sur le smic comme tu as voulu
dans ton programme
en supprimant les seuls qui ont fait
cette absurdité qu'il y à deux fois et
demie plus d'entreprise de 49 salariés
que de 50 salariés
en libérant les emplois à domicile en
ramenant la fiscalité sur le capital à
la moyenne européenne
taxer le capital au niveau du travail ça
a été la plus grande bêtise de françois
hollande
regardez les résultats le nombre
d'exilés fiscal en france a été
multiplié par quatre en cinq ans dix
mille entrepreneurs nous ont quittés
pour aller créer ailleurs pour allez
entreprendre ailleurs nous devons leur
tendre la main
ça passe par une réforme fiscale
profonde qui attire les investisseurs
qui attire les capitaux moins de riches
avec françois hollande et dans le même
temps plus de pauvres jamais le nombre
de bénéficiaires aux minima sociaux
n'avaient été aussi important il n'a
cessé d'augmenter depuis 2012
et là mes amis nous touchons une
différence majeure entre les socialistes
et nous et eux ils veulent qu'ils aient
moins de riches
nous on veut guémon pauvres c'est ça la
différence entre la droite et la gauche
nous remettrons en ordre notre pays nous
remettrons la france dans la course
grâce à de l'audace
grâce à la vérité grâce à de la
modernité
mais de grâce mes amis quand j'entends
parler y compris dans nos propres rangs
de sang de larmes d'austérité de purge
je m'étrangle ouvrez les yeux là aussi
mes chers amis quand on a 70 milliards
de déficit
c'est à dire pas trois et demi pour cent
mais 20 % au regard de notre dépense
alors que l'allemagne elle est en
excédent budgétaire
quand on emprunte chaque mois pour
rembourser ses propres emprunts et pour
payer ses fonctionnaires
quand on a deux mille milliards de dette
quand on est le pays qui dépense le plus
est le pays qui prélève le plus qui
ponctionne le plus parler de cure
d'austérité
mes amis c'est tout simplement abject ne
tombons pas dans le piège de nos
adversaires
utiliser les mots de la gauche c'est
déjà commencé à céder à leur idéologie
vous les avez vu vous les avez vus jeudi
soir j'imagine on nous annonce et la
primaire de là-bas savez ce que c'est
là-bas la belle alliance populaire
bah écoutez moi j'ai surtout vu la
primaire du dab
le distributeur automatique de billets
il aurait dû changer le nom il aurait dû
appeler ça qui veut dépenser des
milliards
vous avez entendu benoît hamon et
propose un revenu universel dont le coût
annuel est égal au budget de l'état
le coût annuel est égal au budget de
l'état
remarquez il est assez cohérent benoît
hamon finalement il a été ministre de
l'éducation nationale le temps des
grandes vacances
il ne croit pas au travail eh bien il
propose tout simplement de les payer
pendant les vacances
arnaud montebourg il veut taxer les
banques
on n'y avait pas pensé et je dois dire
ça c'est typiquement le raisonnement
socialiste ils ont un problème avec la
cdd on taxe les cds des résultats ya
plus de cdd
ils ont un problème avec le temps
partiel on taxe le temps partiel gioda
ya peu de temps partiel ils ont un
problème avec les sages ont taclé stage
résultat il ya plus de stages les
socialistes sont a dit qu à la taxation
on a notre philosophe qui revient de
suisse ça vous rappelle rien un
philosophe qui revient de suisse vincent
peillon se prend pour rousseau oui c'est
vrai qu'il a tout du rêveur solitaire
vincent peillon
mais quand on les écoute sur le voile ou
sur la laïcité
et bien c'est plutôt les délires du
promeneur solitaire
quant à manuel valls manuel valls il est
extraordinaire vous avez remarqué
c'est comme les tarifs du gaz et de
l'électricité
il a changé le 1er janvier 2017 mais il
a changé
pas un peu il était content les 35
heures et pour il était contre l' isf
une pour il était pour le 49-3 il est
contre la vérité c'est qu'on sait plus
très bien à quoi ils fonctionnent on
avale mais on a perdu le manuel
manifestement quand je pense mes chers
amis que françois hollande nous parler
d' alignement de planètes et bien comme
vous jeudi soir j'ai surtout vu beaucoup
de vieilles lunes socialiste
la différence entre eux et nous mes amis
c'est que nous nous voyons le monde tel
qu'il est nous nous voyons la france
décline et nous voyons la france
s'enfoncer et la force de ta candidature
mon cher françois
c'est d'avoir fait un diagnostic juge
sur la situation du pays
un diagnostic sans concession à constat
lucide sur la réalité du monde
faisons en sorte qu'en votant pour
françois fillon et nous fasse entrer
dans ce nouveau monde qui nous tend les
bras
mes chers amis candidats aux
législatives tout va être à réinventer
notre relation au travail à la santé au
monde à la vie jamais sans doute la
politique n'aura été aussi passionnante
mes amis c'est la droite aujourd'hui qui
incarne la modernité c'est la garde la
droite qui va l'incarner à travers le
profil de nos candidats aux élections
législatives
alors françois nous sommes là tes côtés
pour que tu défendes ses valeurs nous
sommes là à tes côtés pour que tous nous
donne les clés de ce nouveau monde
mais nous sommes là surtout pour que tu
nous mène à la victoire
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]